Wahrscheinlich wurde in der letzten zeit kaum etwas so heftig diskutiert wie das verbot von dieselautos in deutschen innenstädten
nach hamburg wird es ab 2019 wohl auch aachen in
nordrhein-westfalen treffen und in absehbarer zeit wahrscheinlich auch noch weitere innenstädte
also hier das pro und contra für diesel oder gegen diese fahrverbote in deutschen innenstädten
sind diese fahrverbote
alternativlos um die luft in den städten besser zu machen oder handelt es sich um eine reine symbol handlung wäre es wirklich
verantwortlich und was wird in zukunft auf uns zukommen das alles und noch viel mehr jetzt bei pixum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja ein thema das heftig in der web community
diskutiert wurde und deshalb jetzt das video hier dazu nach hamburg jetzt also auch noch am anfang juni hat das verwaltungsgericht entschieden
und eine klage der deutschen umwelthilfe stattgegeben und so gibt es auch für die
bezirksregierung köln keine schonfrist mehr sie muss dafür sorgen dass der grenzwert für stickstoffdioxid
ab dem 1 1 2009 10 eingehalten wird die stadt aachen
überschreitet regelmäßig und deutlich den grenzwert der bei 40 mikrogramm pro kubikmeter
luft liegt wie genau die stadt diese auflage umsetzt ist ihre eigene sache
aber hier wird wohl ähnlich in hamburg kein weg an diesel fahrverboten vorbeiführen anders als in der hansestadt
dürfte es hier allerdings nicht reichen wenn einzelne strecken für diese fahrzeuge gesperrt werden es wird wohl zu einem flächendeckenden
verbot kommen dann will man abwarten und schauen was die werte sagen im fall der fälle müssten dann im herbst 2009 10 auch diesel mit
euro-5-norm aus der stadt gesperrt werden von einem diesel verbot kann nur abgewichen werden wenn es genügend andere
maßnahmen gibt die
schadstoffbelastung anderweitig eindämmen können das sagt das grundsatzurteil des leipziger
bundesverwaltungsgerichtes vom 25
20 18 und gibt so den rechtlichen rahmen für
ganz deutschland vor aber er ist selbst auch andere deutsche städte sind mit hochdruck daran die luftreinhaltepläne zu
optimieren und umzusetzen die deutsche umwelthilfe hat nämlich in
27 weiteren städten darunter sind auch düsseldorf frankfurt am main münchen berlin stuttgart essen
gelsenkirchen und so weiter und so fort und das urteil zur stadt aachen gilt hier als
richtungsweisend dazu schreibt die deutsche umwelthilfe auf ihrer website
luftverschmutzung ist nach wie vor eines der größten umweltprobleme unserer zeit trotz europaweit geltender gesetze und dem recht auf saubere luft
werden die grenzwerte für
gesundheitsschädliche luftschadstoffe wie
stickstoffdioxid oder feinstaub in vielen städten und ballungsräumen
regelmäßig überschritten dies belastet die gesundheit der bürger und schadet unserer um
und dem klima bis zu 95 prozent der menschen in den städten europa seien schadstoff konzentrationen
ausgesetzt die ernstzunehmende gesundheitliche schäden zur folge haben hervorgerufen
hauptsächlich durch industrie und verkehr die deutsche umwelthilfe bezieht sich auf studien der europäischen umweltagentur
nach denen es im jahr 2014 mehr als
420.000 vorzeitige todesfälle gegeben hat die man alle auf die feinstaubbelastung in der luft zurückführen kann hinzu kommen knapp
80.000 todesopfer aufgrund hoher
stickstoffdioxid konzentration gesundheitliche schäden verursachen kosten bis zu
940 milliarden euro also bis zu neun prozent des
bruttoinlandsproduktes der eu die umwelthilfe plädiert dafür alle zehn millionen diesel-pkw der abgasstufe 5 und 6 mit neuen
katalysatoren nachzurüsten und zwar auf kosten der hersteller der deutsche städtetag also der zusammenschluss von rund
3.400 städten und gemeinden mit knapp 52 millionen einwohnern lehnt diesel
fahrverbote ab der verband sieht die bundesregierung in der pflicht sie solle die autoindustrie
in die pflicht nehmen und nicht nur software updates sondern auch hardware
nachrüstungen verpflichtend machen viele städte und kommunen meinen dass sie die grenzwerte für stickstoffdioxid
es bei einem absoluten fahrverbot und einführung einer blauen plakette nicht
einhalten könnten doch das ist kein wunder wenn man sich das beispiel hamburg anschaut hier gelten die diesel fahrverbote an zwei besonders
belasteten
straßenabschnitten nämlich 600 meter der max brauer allee in der not diesel mit der euro-6-norm weiterfahren dürfen
und einmal 1,7 kilometer in der stresemannstraße wo das verbot ausschließlich ältere diesel lkw
betrifft bei verstößen sind pkw fahrer 25 euro los und lkw-fahrer
75 euro ausgenommen sind anwohner und deren besucher müllwagen lieferfahrzeuge
rettungsfahrzeuge und taxis die fahrgäste aufnehmen oder absetzen knapp
24.000 in hamburg gemeldete fahrzeuge sind wohl vom diesel fahrverbot betroffen
doch welche alternativen gibt es um die
schadstoffkonzentrationen in den innenstädten zu senken gibt es viele möglichkeiten beispielsweise
die anschaffung von elektrobussen oder apa die nachrüstung von diesel bus flotten prinzipiell müsste der öffentliche nahverkehr
attraktiver gemacht werden beispielsweise
indem mitarbeiter an günstige jobtickets kommen auch der fahrradverkehr kann gefördert werden beispielsweise
durch den umbau der
hauptverkehrsadern städte wie berlin wollen jetzt selbst gegen diese fahrverbote vorgehen beispielsweise
durch mehr elektromobilität mehr
tempo-30-zonen und den ausbau der elektro fahrzeug flotten jetzt erst einmal
haben die verkehrsminister von bund und ländern beschlossen die zugehörigen stickoxid messstationen unter die lupe zu nehmen schließlich
sei es wichtig zu wissen ob die messungen überhaupt ordnungsgemäß
verlaufen
schließlich drohen strafzahlungen von kommunen und städten richtung brüssel
am ende lässt sich festhalten dass die gesundheit der menschen in den städten an erster stelle steht die grenzwerte sind keine
lose empfehlung an die man sich mal mehr mal weniger halten kann doch letztendlich
müsste die bundesregierung jetzt mal ran um eine bundesweite regelung
festzusetzen denn gerichtsurteile
werden jetzt stück für stück auch andere deutsche städte dazu zwingen
fahrverbote zu verhängen die diese allerdings kaum umsetzen geschweige denn
kontrollieren können doch das fatale ist die überschreitung der grenzwerte
passieren
regelmäßig und sind kein geheimnis das heißt also die fakten sind bekannt dass heißt
industrie und politik seien sind an diesem chaos schuld zudem darf die politik auch nicht vergessen wer
dahintersteckt autos und ihre hersteller die spätestens jetzt verpflichtet werden müssten saubere antriebe und
massentaugliche elektroautos auf den markt zu bringen
politik und autoindustrie
haben mir einfach versagt und jetzt für dieses chaos gesorgt reine schadensbegrenzung
in sachen diese krise bringt uns jetzt gar nichts das
bisherige fahrverbote in hamburg ist jedenfalls nicht mehr als ein reines zahlenspiel keine spur von
nachhaltigen umweltschutz denn vielleicht werden die emissionen so dort langfristig und den grenzwert gelangen doch der verkehr wird nur umgeleitet in weniger
belastete straßen heißt also die stickoxide werden umverteilt und keineswegs verringert man könnte das in hamburg also tatsächlich
als bloßen aktionismus bezeichnet mit dem die eu
besänftigt werden soll und strafzahlung abgewendet werden sollen denn die drohen jetzt noch
zusätzlich wenn ihr keine videos zur luftverschmutzung und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
dann um geht ihr die kaputte abo box hier auf youtube und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal
klicks um social and media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
blogger vergessen und wie geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken diese skandal autoindustrie verantwortlich für zehntausende tote bis dann
bleibt dran